now we're going to begin a study one of
the beaches very brutally and major
works the birth of tragedy and I got to
put up here coming out in 1871 for
tourists over 1870 and 1871 crisis and
we're going to spend quite a few
different sessions looking at this
particular work because it's rather
complex such a lot ideas being poured
out within it there are relations to
each other or not as simple as they
might appear at first so what I'm going
to do in this this particular video is
give you a little bit of introduction to
talk about some of the easy
misinterpretations that people often
make when they're approaching this for
the first time at home with those and
then everybody start digging into some
of the real meat of the work we're going
to look at the opposition and the
confluence the DNS again and the
colognian as Nietzsche is describing
them we're going to look at Nietzsche's
take Greek poetry and artwork and then
arena again I'm not actually going to
get to the bottom of it we're going to
begin to look at his interpretation of
Greek tragedy which he thinks is
absolutely central and he thinks has
implications not only for classical
studies for history for you know
humanities-based look at the past he
thinks it has great implications for his
present and future and I would say as
well for our present and future so what
do we need to say about the work first
uh well I thought it would be kind of
useful to look at
hñ itself says about it he's uh he's
making rather qualified remarks about
his own work in this case about 15 years
later one of the things that he says
about it is that it's poorly written
heavy-handed embarrassing and that's you
know understand artists novelists poets
painters philosophers historians you
know many of us are embarrassed by our
first works
yeah and others that there's an old
expression
I remember this coming across this when
I was working on my dissertation which I
never published I have the same
experience except I didn't publish my
work somebody said to me the only good
dissertation as a dissertation that's
actually finished that's done and it's
only good because you used it as a sort
of battleground for ideas or a sort of
artists workplace you know it's dog with
paint anywhere or you used it as some
preliminary studies for what you're
going to do afterwards
yeah this is rather important you know
when it comes to the life of the mind
just like the life of Technology or the
life of sport or performance or anything
like that
our first efforts are usually not our
best performances so Nietzsche is
looking back at this and saying it lacks
logical nicety and a so sure if it's a
message of dispenses that he can't prove
worse than that suspects the very notion
improved being a book written for
initiates of music for men and Kristin
music and held together by a specialist
experiences my Shibboleth for the
highbrow Confraternity so you know he
said he's not entirely happy with what
he's got here and this work is quite a
bit different from later works that he's
going to run but he also does put his
finger on some of the really key things
and you know well he should he is the
one who wrote this book right he says
how are we to define that the NSTIC
spirit in my book answered that question
with the authority the character
disciple today of taking the talking to
the matter today out of doubt though
she's more discretion less eloquence now
after you does that servant self
deprecation uses one of the cardinal
questions here is that of the Greek
attitude towards pain towards summary
what kind of sensibility did these
people have was that sensibility
constant or did it change from
generation to generation
should we attribute the ever increasing
desire of the Greeks for beauty in the
form of banquets ritual ceremonies new
cults to some fundamental lack the
melancholy disposition perhaps an
obsession of pain or does their
commitment to the tragic death image of
all that his blog evil perplexing
destructive ominous and human experience
what in short we had the Greek mind
turned to tragedy a sense of euphoria
maybe sheer exuberance Restless health
and power but in that case what does
Connecticut's of that DNS yet frenzy
which gave rise to tragedy and comedy
alike can frenzy the Ute is something
that is not a symptom of decay disorder
over references there's such a thing
that a leanest answer that question as a
neurosis arising from health from the
youthful condition of the race so he's
proposing these really simple questions
every society every great literature
every culture that begins to reflect on
itself to pour itself out unfold itself
and develop tensions with that song he
has to grapple with certain fundamental
issues and these aren't just you know
metaphysical issues like it was
everything beta or you know what's the
difference with appearance with reality
not just technical questions at what
should we head towards what is a good
not just political questions like how
should society to organize what is
justice but also with what Nietzsche
here is opposing as aesthetic questions
usually we need to think of the statics
we think that beauty part all that's
first employees are what is beauty
Nietzsche conceives of these things what
should our response be to life to the
nature of reality aesthetics ethics
metaphysics are not neatly disentangle
from each other for thicker like
Nietzsche and the reason why they're
done is because he thinks for the
ancient Greece they weren't as well not
a man in true sense and once you start
to disentangle say Alex or theory from
these other things you actually make it
less than what it was you deprive us
so whether mixed it together is when
they
there's the greatest advocacy you might
say there's a few other things that I
want to read from later on in the work
actually just two things sort of set the
tone after he's talked not only about
the Apollonia and the DNS yen but about
something else which remember we're
going to look at much more closely than
later sessions the socratic or
Alexandria response she says in each
after age the same phenomenon occurs
over and over the avid will finds means
to maintain and perpetuate its creatures
in life by spreading over existence with
blandishments of illusion we're going to
see why those things are so important
one man is enthralled by a zest for
knowledge and as persuaded he can
staunch the eternal wound of being with
its health and others of the guy was a
little part which flutters tantalizing
before his eyes yet another hasn't
weighed up by the metaphysical solace
that light falls on indestructible
beneath the whirlpool of appearances
these are three major responses
what is the Socratic what is the
then he goes on he says not to mention
even commoner and more powerful
illusions which will holds in readiness
at any moment the three kinds of
illusion I have named the answer only to
the noble nature's who resent the burden
of existence more deeply than the rest
of who therefore requires special the
guidance to make them forget its birth
what we call culture is entirely
composed of such a guidance so this is a
very important point and I'm going to
come back to that in just one moment the
other thing that I want to read
Nietzsche makes a contrast here between
a sort of area toward a european way of
looking at things this is part of what
led him to let his works to be
appropriated by the National Socialism
but we can sort of strip it away
it's think of these as sort of ideal
types he says what distinguishes the
Aryan conception not the fall which he
sees as somatic but as sort of the
primal crime the primal trauma or terror
sense what distinguishes the Aryan
conception is an exalted notion of
active sin as the properly for immediate
virtue this notion provides us with the
ethical substratum of pessimistic
tragedy which comes to be seen as a
justification of human ills that is to
say if human guilt as well as the
sovereign purchased by that guilt again
is contrasting this to the you know
somatic biblical
being supportive you know later on you
could say to follow the devil and that
it's a transposition into that that that
artistic production the tragedy at the
heart of the things he says there's a
thoughtful hearing that's not disclosed
to whittle away the contrary at the
center of the universe is seen by him as
an inter penetration of several worlds
this is the thing this is a point worth
sort of lingering over for Nietzsche
reality is complex dynamic active and it
involves forces not just inter
penetrating each other but in tension
with each other overcome each other
transforming into each other sometimes
subordinating the other or transforming
it in clashing with each other and what
is right is not given in some sort of a
an optic view from above that covers
everything it has to develop on this
this ferment between different
perspectives different commitments
different writings and movements or ways
of being and living so he says there's a
country at the center of the universe
there there's a campus not in the sense
of everything being totally indistinct
and not be able to make any sense of it
you might think of it as rather saying
there's too much sense for it all to
make sense
and so he has to battle it out and this
is a very different notion of the the
fundamental basis of the universe and of
good and evil than that which we see say
Judaism Christianity Islam or even in
neoplatonism philosophically Nietzsche
is articulating something that is in
many ways more like the Babylonian
looking at things interesting enough
that one into science if you look at the
aluminum live and the representation of
things there the imposition by martyr
order upon things order that wasn't
originally there and be imposed requires
force requires coercion the generation
of human beings not made an image of God
but in order to serve the God so the
guys don't have to war with each other
because they're so so powerful human
beings instead of being made of dust and
the breath of God being made the blood
of a sacrificed guy these were all very
much in line with what a chest
as per median area that's where it's not
so much sin as crime which is the the
central norm cameras being used
so let's know after we sort of set the
stage for this let's look now at a few
common misunderstanding is that that
occurred with respect to what we have
going on in this bar is this constant
opposition between the MSDN about
colonial times and observe this many
times taking place in classes and
reading groups when people come to this
book for the first time because meetcha
is such a great thinker and not just a
you know intellectual metaphysical
philosophy a philosophical thing to
agree that arranging things and
categories and some of these so this but
he's also an artist he's also a
rhetorician he's also a metaphor pointer
and developer because he's so good at
that
it's very easy to be seduced into
thinking that this one is only about
these two things and then what Nietzsche
is providing me here is a metaphysics in
which is either this or this so I want
to go over a few sort of ground you can
come up ground rules if you want or
maybe key ideas for interpreting this
work this is coming about after reading
through the whole work of thinking about
this many many times over the last
it's over simplify that take that this
well the Dina skin and the acromion our
responses to reality the reality for
Nietzsche is not what we typically
represented as our representations by
being representations are already sort
of a departure from reality and yet an
internet further intervention of mixing
the stuff up within reality but what is
reality like fundamentally there is
discord there is permanent
there has conflict there is exuberance
everything that goes with life when you
ask what is the point of life by the
time that you actually begin to ask that
question you're already you know several
stages remove from their life by it self
generating pulsing moving eating
drinking populating reproducing finding
all these sorts of things design and
reality itself is is for each of us this
massive just flux constantly of beings
which are coming into being and going
out of being and which are you know
attacking and cooperating with each
other which are you know joining each
other being bothered by each other and
he also talks about this in terms of
effect Nietzsche is a great student of
how the effect were the emotional or the
desire as part of ourselves reveals to
us truth reality what's going on all
those sorts of things that they would
normally
for the intellect science or you know
abstraction
now that the Edison is a response to
this reality it's in response it's not
only the response and it doesn't
responds in part by mimicking that
reality by mastering yet in a sense by
becoming part of it or letting itself
become yet once again part of it by
losing itself but that doesn't mean that
the initiated by itself is that
underlying reality that is yet further
more foundational than the response the
aquilonian response is to produce order
form differentiation stability to impose
those things to seduce it to those
things to tell a story rather than want
to use a Shakespearean phrase that gets
used by Faulkner to tell a story that is
not a tale told by an idiot signifying
nothing which is with you know the
constant threat of an addition but to
tell a story that seems to have a point
that you can articulate and you can put
your finger on not necessarily a point
that makes sense of it everything all by
itself in a philosophical systematic way
because that's a third response and
beyond both of these two there's another
response to this is what gets called
cravaack
Alexander responds and this is something
quite different but it's also something
real so it's not just a matter of either
the addition or not ammonia there's
actually the third term and there's
actually a fourth term like I you know
mentioned and then that passage that I
quoted the there we go in age after age
of same phenomenon occurs over and over
the heaven will finds means to maintain
and perpetuate his creatures of life by
spreading over existence the blanche
fits of illusion not to mention he says
even commoner and more powerful
illusions which the will holds and
readiness at any moment so you know
losing oneself stay in consumerist
culture a common response in our long
time mike phirman each in perspective
will explore this a little bit later on
that might not be the initiative that
might not be not Vilonia that might not
even be Socratic or Alexander that might
in fact I think it probably actually is
its own type of response they in some
way more superficial response one that
is less no there's an ability to this
even though Nietzsche is so firmly
against this it says this is what grew
in tragedy this is what's screwing
things up even now meetcha recognizes
the nobility in this so there are other
responses to the problem of life to the
problem making sense of things which
don't fit into this schema the other
thing that I want to point out is that
the there's a temptation
water to want to see things leaving out
this other stuff to want to see things
only in terms of an opposition between
Apollonian and Dionysian this is a big
problem because if you do that you're
going to first a lot miss the central
point of what this book is about which
is that tragedy Greek tragedy when it's
working well it actually fuses the two
of these together and it doesn't so it
doesn't do that just by you know - of
this in the - of this or pound of this
mixed in with a pound of this they
actually affect each other in a fairly
complex ways so it's a mistake to say
well everything is either uncle deputy
NSA act or it's on Vilonia now let's go
around trying to identify which is which
they have in fact then if you want to
get down to it that would actually be
much more like a Socratic response or
one of those lower responses that is
criticism not actually readmission or
response so it wouldn't be true to his
work there's also a danger not just with
tragedy but with all the other things
that he's he's talking about in thinking
that any of them are purely the
initiative or purely Apollonia because
he doesn't say that he actually sees
things that are that are sort of a limit
condition of being purely beingness you
know sort of like falling back into that
chaos just a moment so you know I see
the same thing being done
nice dualistic sort of philosophical way
of categorizing things you know another
great example of this to more
contemporary examples in media studies
with Marshall McLuhan they talk about
hot media and coal be cool right as soon
as somebody starts reading those ports
they don't pay attention one fluid
that's was saying about some of these
things and they go around this well
that's hot that's cool or if we look at
the difference between speech and right
you know people read area down or people
read Plato's Phaedrus or they read other
things you know Walter or any of these
other people who talk about the
difference between oral and written
cultures and immediately they want to go
around and identify well that's oral
that's written yeah there is kind of a
fun you know side to can aggressive
things but the reason why I would want
to categorize is so that we can wrap our
heads around we don't want to categorize
just for the sake of doing it because
that turns out to kind of a pointless
exercise
that's certainly that's what
categorization that ain't going to help
you deal with the problem of luck
so Nietzsche is using these these
concepts Tennessean not morning as tools
as categories but not as entirely
exclusive diametrically opposed
categories that that allow us to to
understand everything slowly the Germans
in their composition
so let's know they actually look
[Music]
on board
what's what you have this
characterizations Dennison
so let's look first yeah what he says
about nature human beings emerge from
from nature from the world and we're a
creature were being word organism and
we're different than other ones we're in
certain ways more complex than the other
ones but we are in continuity with them
for something like nature the first
distinction that he brings about is
talking about the difference between
intoxication and these are for Anita not
only psychological or spiritual but even
physiological things that that curve
phenomena that we can we can note that
we can relate to and he says spelling
this out let us begin by viewing them as
the separate realms dream onea in
intoxication it wasn't a dream according
to the lucretius that the barbarous gods
and goddesses first presented themselves
to the mind of man and you know dreams
visions that sort of stuff you actually
see this in not just ancient poetry but
also ancient philosophy it was the
literature
that sort of things well that great
sculptor Phidias beheld in a dream the
entrancing bodies of more than human
beings the light wise if anyone has two
greek poets about the mystery of what a
creation they too have reverted to
dreams and instructed him the fair
illusion of the dreams fear and the
production of which every man crews
himself an accomplished artist that's
something we're thinking about we're not
all great artists we're not great you
know arranging words and phrases and
metaphors and rhymes poetry or musicians
but when it comes to our imaginary life
are dreaming by a game mechanic creature
that we are we all have these capacities
and we can form incredible sets of
images so he says here we enjoy an
immediate apprehension of form shapes
all shapes speak to us directly nothing
seems indifferent or redundant so this
is a dream we should also think
imagination despite the high intensity
with which these dream realities exist
for us we still have a resident residual
sensation of the our illusions and the
frequency not to say normality the
experience is born out of the passage of
many poets so we have dreamed and we not
only have you know vision we have
effective connects
to the things that were dreaming we feel
as well even if it's just the sense yes
this is the right proportion these
things are the way they want to be and
it's an illusion now he says here he
says the perfection of these conditions
in contrast to our imperfect manage of
waiting reality there's sort of a to do
to the imaginary or to the dream there's
a consistency the coherence that is
actually lacking in our ordinary
experience of reality that's one of the
things that illusion grants illusion
brings the possibility of wholeness of
things being in in perfect harmony
making sense the perfection of these
conditions furnishes the symbolic analog
of the sustained faculty in widget when
it's the earth or to make life possible
and worth living
this is a fundamental response agent
thinks that just on a physiological
bodily psychical oh why do we dream why
do we imagine because that enables us to
deal with what that heals us so the
Apollonia is really something rooted in
our nature and how we respond to the
rest of the reality so the image of
Apollo must incorporate that thin line
which the dream event remain across of
your penalty of becoming pathological
and imposing itself - oh if this is a
crass reality a discrete limitation of
freedom from all extravagant bridges the
sappy and tranquility of the plastic job
one of the things that we're going to
see going along is also Springs
limits if the dream is going to be
successful there's certain things that
should not occur with little dream like
opposing is this a dream
because then that because the jungle
things back into chaos what about
intoxication well one of the things that
me to talk about here is the Creek
Indian individual individual as long as
the principle individuation of
separation beings apart from each other
what is it that makes me me and you do
rather than you know us being fused
together being the same thing so
incoherently distinguished mass the
principle of individuation something
allows us to be different under each
other there falls on the side of the
anomaly the Apollonia by the way it
works imposes but well there well we are
sentient beings we are also not
separately
we are also beings who are together in
this world and the world is not just me
it is not just view it is not just all
these other things it's all of us
together and there's a sense in which
the loss of that unity north's at us at
human beings so he says if we get up to
this far the glorious transport which
arises in man even from the very depths
of nature at the shatter on the brink it
be an independent Avanti on us then we
are in a position to happen in the
essence of the industry at rapture so no
this is ecstatic in a way that is
fundamentally different than when this
over here who's closest to dianna G is
provided by physical intoxication DNS
the act stirrings arise either through
those potions of which all primitive
races speak Americans it's actually
worth you know very short digression
just about every culture that has
developed past you know just hunting
gathering even some of them out there
gathered or something greed they very
quickly figure out how to make something
that will put them in a different state
they usually figure out how to ferment
so so nearly everybody has got something
that they manage and ferment issues
really spoil anyway the fermentation is
very key in this yak you're taking
things and you're letting other things
affect them and produce new things out
of that even just think about the
fermenting carboy of beer Devil's
bubbling taking place just about every
culture figures out how to make
something that will intoxicate you
oftentimes put a few things and then
they begin to use it and then they begin
to experience something new reality in a
different way it's very important
remember Dionysus the DN a-- c FD a--
missus is the god of life the god of
intoxication the god of friends so DN s
be experience arises where the
influences are kind of potions or
through we can have a response that ste
in his head without even thinking we
didn't talk about I'm high on life well
that would be something like this or
through the powerful approach of spring
which penetrates with joy the whole
frame of nature many of us are so
detached from the natural world and were
able to shut it out in so many different
ways or to only take tiny little
portions of it that it's hard for us to
sensitise I remember the very first time
comparative religion class that I was
teaching about primal religions that
we're talking about the sky god
fortunately I was in a place that
actually had a very good view it took my
class outside and I have them
participate but just look up and if you
have to spend the time to do that and
you look at just the immensity what
you're surrounded by and then you start
to notice things going on flights of
birds lay clouds the wind all those
sorts of natural occurrences when you
don't simply take those for granted
anymore then you can actually start to
have some sort of sense of what nature
was like for those you know in the past
from whom will removal by are
technologically influenced environment
the coming of spring is a national event
for us it's just a calendar date and we
often run put at the wrong time
shouldn't be this this particular day it
means something for ancient peoples it
means something for those who are not
from nature and it introduced a kind of
intoxication there are all sorts of
other things that can do that as well so
he's a soul stir the individual forgets
the hall whereas over here individual is
marcado's but there's also the
possibility of identification with
another individual same with the
distance or Achilles
recommitment are quite a bit extra
pictorial on any of the figures of epic
or tragedy there's this possibility of
identification
individual so he says it's you talked
about he's giving it a comparison here
it's the same thing SDI power which had
been able to terminate drove
ever-increasing crowds of people singing
and dancing for place too close and
that's another important aspect well how
is this revealed through song through
dance through music we're going to get
to what kind of music in just a moment
the bakit courses of the Greeks and
their precursors in the ancient behind
as far back as Babylon the Pardee astok
psyche and he says there are people who
either from lack of experience we're out
of sheer stupidity turn away from such
phenomena strong in the sense of their
own sanity label them either mocking
their fittingly endemic diseases as
primitive and they want to reject that
sort of thing but with a DNS yeah this
is actually being more in touch with
reality rather than being out of touch
with it so he says not only does the
bond between man and man coming before
once more by the magic of the data see
how great that nature itself while
alienated or subjected rises again to
celebrate the reconciliation with her
prodigal son man human beings so one of
the things that's taking place through
the DNS yet is the reading unit the
reunification of human beings with each
other with their own nature grasping
what they are as parts of the natural
world and he's got some great examples
of this which I'm actually
to skip over one thing I do want to say
is he read from here man now expresses
himself through song and dance as the
member of a higher community has
forgotten to walk up speak and is on the
brain of tea and a chicken wing as he
dances so what's occurring here there's
an again identification through
intoxication through an ecstatic being
outside of itself and Nietzsche says
something really worked here no longer
the artist he has himself become a work
of art the productive power of the whole
universe is now manifested in his
transports the glorious satisfaction of
the primordial one
so now Nietzsche in the next section
says look we've looked at a nature now
both of these are necessary for human
beings both of them are used by human
beings
what about art what about how that plays
itself we've examined these as the
private performative forces arising
directly from nature without the
mediation in Canaris once you mix in the
human artist and this happens very very
girl over there beings already in a
history right once you mix in the artist
now things go to a higher level because
artistry can among other things that can
involve the Deena C act or it can
involve the Apollonia you can reproduce
them it can take them to a higher power
so it says at this stage artistic urges
are satisfied directly on the one hand
the dreams perfection was quite
independent to the intellectual rank the
artistic development to the individual
on the other hand up through an extent
reality that once again takes another
company individual and may even destroy
we're all sardine into a mystical
experience in the collective now what
happens with the artists
he says heaven set down on these general
principles and distinctions we now
return to the Greeks in order to realize
what degree the formative forces of
nature were developed in them this will
allow us to assess the relation of the
Greek artists as prototypes or to use
Aristotle's expression his imitation of
nature because birds arts been conceived
of as an imitation of nature from Plato
from the Aristotle running throughout in
Western culture not as by itself being
the way in which human beings
participate in and contribute to nature
although you can't see a strain of that
I rather reaches very clearly
anti-christian you do see a strain of
this how human beings can participate in
nature and its reduction or in its
unfolding in some Christian society
because we go too far from the true
nature now one other thing that he says
before we go into the artisans bearing
he says there's another point about
which we do not have to conjecture at
all there's a profound gift he says
separating that the initiatic Greaves
from the DNS yak barbarians again this
goes to that point not every decision
thing is the same and if you try to have
the DNS be an unmediated with nothing
else there you actually end up you might
say getting away
or losing losing grass he says
throughout the great debates and
civilizations we find an evidence of DNS
D at celebrations which stand to the
Greek type in much the same relation as
the bearded satyr stands to the god
Dionysus so there's there's a connection
of analogy there DNS is the guy the
Sailor is just a stand-in - we were in a
spin-off or a reflection of that that
guy the sexual concern except
celebration was almost universally this
Nietzsche
a complete sexual promiscuity over
writing and reform of established tribal
law all the standards urges the mind
revelation of his occasions until they
reach that Perry Aksum lust and cruelty
which always struck me as the witch's
cauldron para the par excellence well I
mean you don't necessarily have to tie
this injustice sexuality to some
violence all the other things inside the
point that he's made in here is that
when the DNS here is just the DNS again
it sort of wears itself out it just
produces these endless cycles of we're
gonna do things normally for a while
then everything goes crazy and we run
the bowls or we have carnival or we it's
bigger t over to here or pick whatever
you like you know but then after you
after that's occurred instead role was
the point
what does it actually provide it may
have provided moments where the
divisions between for a while and it
needed corrective every so often just to
keep things up of course there's not
much
it's only with Greeks where the DNS game
is tied in with the odd Maloney as he
puts it
who what kept Greeks safe was the crowd
imposing image of Apollo but holding up
the head of the Gorgon to those rural
and road tests the initiate forces
subdued them duraguard is immortalized
Paulo's magenta majestic rejection of
all licence and he says you know this
actually breaks down at certain points
in the Greek Greek history as well so he
says that after pacification represents
the most important event in the history
of Greek ritual the two greatest
activists Genesis and Apollo have been
reconciled each feels obligated
henceforth to keep his balance so you
only really according to nature you only
really have working to their full
potential being fully what they can be
unfolding unpacking themselves all the
way if there's actually a creative
tension running between the two of them
flash running between them and one of
the questions that you could ask here
that meet you himself
does not enhance yes okay whoever loses
this match
he says the Apollo holds up the Gorgons
head which is what freezes things to
stone to the vmsu
does that mean that the Apollonia impose
this completely but the Apollonian
itself has to respect that what
condition was the Apollonian to actually
respect it as well and why should that
the initiative respond to that and so
they're just saying I'll find some way
around here
screw you America to let you freeze me
into place there's maybe something else
going on here that's not fully
articulated yeah I just leave that open
as a question think about let's go back
to these two characters and let's think
now about the artist so he starts out
talking about music and he says in every
exuberant joy there's heard an undertone
of terrorist whisper lament over
irreparable loss that's the DNS it's as
though these brief festivals of
sentimental trade of nature were coming
to the floor as though nature were
promoting the fact that were
fragmentation her detailed composition
into separate individuals that's again
Mary do you miss the chance and gestures
of these revelers so ambiguous in the
formation represented an absolute no to
the world of the Homeric Greece their
DNS yet musics
bread a raw terror and a deep shudder so
there's a DNS yet way of doing music the
Greeks like he said had already been
familiar with the Apollonia type of
music he says music is log metal
familiar to the Greeks is of not baloney
and art there's a regular beat like that
of waves lapping along the shore but
what music yes it is actually regularity
that's why music could in fact later on
in the Middle Ages become one of the
quadrivium liberal arts that he had to
do with what with mathematics relation
one that's already noted
I played it bye-bye aerosol that's very
Apollonia visible so I says Paulo's
music was a Doric architecture of sound
of barely hinted sounds such as are
proper to the kisser
technical the type of essentially heart
is thinking that that way strings that
are not played all at the same time but
but in in turn those carry elements
which characterize the initiative is a
can accurate music quite generally the
heart shaking power of tone the uniform
strength of melody the incomparable
resources of harmony all these elements
have been carefully kept at a distance
as being in constant with the Apollonia
norm so there is two different types of
music and eventually which is going to
win out that's going to be the DNS yeah
music so it says the Apollonia greek
being confronted with with dns deaq
phenomena muslim looked upon this with
some degree of surprise and that
surprise would have been further
increases they matter later realized
with a shudder that all this was not so
alien to him that his popcorn
consciousness was but a thin veil hiding
from a whole deity at route so again
well these are together the Greek who
has made sense of the world the classic
read by the not alone yet still has this
going on within him or her because there
is human being because this is part of
what it is to be a human being and the
world can't all being air in length and
quiet tinkling music small measure
yeah now March there has to be this
other side as well so he says in order
to comprehend this we have to take down
the Apollonia edifice the culture stone
by stone until we discover its
foundation so we have to deconstruct the
world this is the first day I have
struck by the marvelous shapes of the
Living God the fact that the bottom that
makes my Nepal was one God about many
should not mislead us the same derived a
thought is most complete representation
of Hollow generate in the whole world
and in this sense we may consider Paulo
to follow the Father Knows
so the mythology which you know if you
one more time we represent Greek
mythology as well this was their
religion and we think about it sort of
like going to Temple is going to church
but these were actually quite different
and the Greek content with their own
religion came in part through stories
many of which were not known as a later
but even more through artistic
production through statues through
architecture through rituals and out of
those rituals come tragedy and other
poetry also through epic so the Greeks
are encountering their gods through the
medium of human productions that are
providing these things to them the most
urgent productions of primarily
populonia sort of nature so he says what
was the radical need out of which that
illustrious society of Olympian beings
sprained and he says whoever approaches
the Olympians with a different
so we're looking at them you know that's
one within the act in a traditional way
we 1001 religion to be something either
terrible or something perfect you know
in our society or we just want to be
left alone by some people but usually
that's because what he says whoever
approaches the olympians with a
different religion is heart seeking
moral elevation sanctity spirituality
and loving kindness will be forced to
turn away from them and ability over
disappointment but if you you know if
you read their stories of the Greek gods
they were screw up so it's from that
they're fighting with each other
cheating on each other playing tricks
sometimes trying to kill each other off
being jealous being angry raping mortals
seducing mortals screwing up people's
lives producing Wars all sorts of things
like that right so he says nothing these
days reminds us of asceticism high
intellect of duty we're confronted by a
luxuriant triumphant existence which
defines the good and bad indifferent
that's something really critical when it
comes to the alcohol that's something
which is good to distinguish it from the
later thing that we're going to talk
about as the Socratic or Alexander
what's being individuated what's being
represented is not being put forward as
being perfect in a moral sense like he
says
we're confronted by the during transit
existence which did identify the good
and the man taeksoo spirits and Zeus is
supposed to be known pretty good and in
a lot of respects
he's the protective travelers he's the
one who cares for those who's you know
rights are being transgressed so you'd
better watch out as it was this might
get you if you know your music before
the little workman and at the same time
he's got no problem Gina's wife hiding
all these things from her raising
children all sorts of other children you
know he's a morally ambivalent character
we could say he says the Olympian Magic
Mountain opens itself to us showing its
barriers what are the roots was the
Greeks were keenly aware of the terrors
of immersive existence in order to be
able to live at all they had to place
before them the The Shining fantasy of
the other beings their tremendous
distrust of the Titanic forces of nature
Moya or fate mercilessly enthroned
beyond the knowable world the vulture
which fed upon the great philanthropist
Prometheus terror a lot drawn by Y as an
Odysseus but because before I do not
think of Odysseus just that guy who
never tells dad sleep with his mom
Odysseus was a wise man who suffered
adversity triumphed overhead rule the
land wisely you know produce great
things but this this horrible thing
occurred to him without him even
understanding it without you
but in a certain sense being wrapped up
in it as being being unable to avoid it
that's more the initiative right the
album omean arises as a needed response
to that sort of thing that's going to
happen so he says in order to live it
all the Greeks he had to construct these
deities the Apollonia need for beauty
headed develop the olympian hierarchy of
joy is a beautiful expression the
hierarchy of joy by slow degrees from
the original Titanic tired of terror
what does he mean there well look at
what happened before the Olympian gods
what led up to them you have the Titans
right and even before then we had a war
on us who is you know just this crazy D
in this yeah
destructive you know father strike force
right and then you know we get Kronos
the father love at least you know six of
the Olympian gods but what is the promos
to Kronos had actually you know
castrated his own father and take it
power that's not a novel defense that's
a pretty DNA
sort of thing and he swallows his own
children because there's a prophecy that
one of his children they don't replace
him so he swallows them alive again
horrible things right
the other Titans how are they rotors you
know there's these hundred handed words
there's for me this there's evidence
there's always a consumes all these
great forces well the Apollonia Olympian
gods provide you to something compelling
that and they don't you know completely
erase they replaced so he says the gods
justified human life
how did they justify human life another
beautiful phrase by nature by living it
themselves they do many of the higher
weapon
nature calls us the only satisfactory
theodicy ever invented
what is the theodicy comes from the
Greek word for God sales and way or
method or tanker structured way to do it
totally the theodicy is the
justification of the ways of God so when
people say I don't understand why God
does this sort of stuff lets us happen
if you try to provide an explanation for
that you're providing that's the Odyssey
what are the Greeks providing with these
stories of the off of the Olympian gods
they're providing the theodicy to
everybody something that a lot of people
say okay maybe I don't fully understand
everything yeah but at least this is a
good story and I feel better now and I
feel better now because I'm actually
able to like look at this here this
madness think about this inject might
stop there and he says now it became
possible to stand in the wisdom of
Salinas oh that's heaven for claiming it
was the worst evil of man to die soon of
the second worst room to die at all miss
elaina's had said this is Dinah's yet
best thing for you would have been it
had never been born
second best
dai - - so it says it should have become
apparent by now that the harmony with
nature which we late comers regard such
nostalgia is by no means a simple
inevitable condition to be found at the
gateway that the culture ten paradise
modern modern human beings have
misconstrued what goes on in prying up
cultures which are essentially the
initiated unless they're able to find
some Apollonia way of dealing with this
and this is very vital this is something
which is at the root on a Greek tragedy
that every sort of cultural renewal in
Nietzsche's beer this is a good place to
leave off for the moment we've looked at
these two different responses in the
initiatic we've looked at some of their
interplay we looked at how they rise out
of the nature of human beings and how
they develop themselves where the
production the artistic production by
human beings of the Olympian gods comes
in and next we're actually going to turn
to different kinds of artistry besides
is we're going to look at poetry and the
other plastic arts which are essentially
alone in poetry in some respects so I'm
sorry
who's doing this and then we're going to
look at some tragedy fuses these
together so that's what we're going to
do next